Do you have anyone who has to lock their door at night because
they're scared because they get like hate mail? Dude, she's such
a self-victimizing loser. It's so gross. This would be >> the
clip. Play the clip. Play the clip. Dude, get out of my chat.
Get out of my Get out of my Discord. Get the [__]
out of here, man. Right. >> Oh, shut the [__]
up, you stupid Really?
>> Oh, Jesus Christ.
>> You please just explain the situation. Okay, so there
is a clipping Discord that I'm a part of, okay? It's been there
for a while. I if Substances in it, um
couple people here are in it, right? And we post Basically,
I will ask for links to stuff. Uh I will suggest clips to people.
I'll retweet other people's clips, right? Yeah, we talk about
[__] We laugh. We have a good time. And basically,
they're trying to post like cut-up logs with absent any context
as if this is like an evil doxing server. Destiny wants this
to go and flow into his greater narrative that I'm running like
a cabal that's been working against him, that hates him, and
wants to undermine everything he's ever done.
Apparently, Dickers is fighting with Stardust on Twitter. Hold
on.
Okay. Hold on. Hold on. So, wow, commentary channel that's okay
with flagging people for targeted harassment and then a bit said,
"If Bad Empanada a doxxing server creator criticizing him and
actively called for his audience to give him more creators' doxx
so he can publish it, would you condemn people for flagging him?
Honest question."
And then right here, Bad Empanada threatened to doxx me when
I first ever interacted with him by posting this image below
one of his below one of his psychotic tweets. This comparison
y'all make between Destiny to Bad Empanada will never convince
anyone. Oh, this person's totally moronic.
He's asking if somebody who is a doxxer, like a known doxxer
who is rampantly doxxing people, right? Which is Destiny.
Now, I don't know what that what you think Bad Empanada does
or doesn't do. They're now threatening to dox multiple people.
They're menacing multiple people with being doxxed. Like, come
on, man. Come on, man. And by the way, it's not about threats.
It's about who he's doxxed as well, right? Threatening to dox
you, well, that's one thing. That's really bad,
Destiny doxxed a bunch of people. BadBunny has doxxed a bunch
of people.
You're missing the obvious subtext of my post. BadBunny has doxxed
and threatened to dox creators. Nobody would criticize reporting
those videos.
Thickers, I hope you grow into a full human being someday, is
what BadBunny says in return.
Argument? Any arguments? Do we have arguments? Could we hear
an argument? Is there an argument?
Where's the argument? Just say you're afraid to argue with Thickers.
That's all you got to say. Just say you're afraid to argue with
Thickers. Just actually keep it to yourself. Actually just laugh,
right?
Oh, boy. Uh, thanks. I've got no hope you'll ever improve. By
the way, while I've got you, how the do you bleed on about misogyny
online and then downplay Destiny's treatment of women? No, it's
a it's a pattern of behavior, for sure. I thought it was irresponsible.
Um, and again, when all that stuff exploded, I I took a pretty
firm stance at like I thought it was, you know, that's not something
you do to a friend, right? Um, and I think that's something even
he would have admit. Like, that's not something that you do to
a friend.
What about to your ex-wife or wife at the time? To be fair, when
he was doing this, he was also like totally gaslighting his wife
and being like, "No, me and Lauren Southern aren't together in
any way. No, you're going crazy. Maybe you need therapy. Hey,
wife, maybe you need therapy cuz you think I'm somebody else.
You think I'm this Lauren Southern woman. You're you're insane.
So, maybe you should go to therapy." Also, while sending her
to other people without her consent. And you guys want this guy
to be in charge of your political movement. You're all lining
up behind this guy. You are worthless. You are
But, the this whole situation is very
complex and stuff, you know?
but yeah, I mean, you know, it's it's it's hard to I guess explain
my stance on this whole thing, I guess, if that makes sense,
you know?
It's so weird that and people like in this space were trying
to call me like a sweeper for him when I I think I took a pretty
strong stance like against
him cheering those images, right? And I What is this strong stance?
Is it a really strong stance to say it's really wrong it's wrong
to do that? Was that a very strong stance?
Start us is that the strong stance you took? Oh, that was wrong.
Oh, that was that was bad.
Very strong stance. Even he has admitted that, you know, it was
irresponsible to talk to somebody he barely knew.
but I also can acknowledge that he's a victim as well of having
all that stuff leaked. I can also acknowledge that um
that, you know, again, most men in his position are not very
different from And um most men in his most men with
influence than he has are equally boomers, you know, and boomers.
Most men with less influence than he has are said also men share
nudes all the time and everybody does what he does and also he's
just the same as Do you see Do you see how it's the same concerted
effort to degrade anything appearing to be like a a principle,
like being morally good in any way? Oh, just everybody's bad.
Everybody's Everybody's like a total piece of filth like Destiny.
Really? He's just honest about what a piece of filth he is, so
shouldn't you be like Destiny and like total filth, totally like
worthless
No. No. Uh even if even if that were possibly true,
no, we shouldn't just we shouldn't just allow that. No, you're
wrong. You're You're wrong. You're wrong on multiple levels.
You're wrong in that premise, but even if it were true, no, we
shouldn't all just aspire to be
That that's not That's not the way it should be. Come on, man.
Um I don't believe when men like grandstand about like sharing
pictures and stuff, I don't believe a single one of these dudes,
okay? Any of these content creators who are like, "Oh, I'd never
send to nudes with my friends." Shut the [__] up.
Like I know I know for a fact that most men, if they have received
nudes from a girl, they have shared it with at least one of their
guy friends. Okay? At least one of their guy friends. It's not
right. It's not something men should mention doing. I don't think
it's something men should do. But, do I think that this is remotely
not normal?
No, maybe and maybe again that's maybe very pessimistic of me,
but Wow. This is what happens when you disconnect like
total overall like sum total of harm.
This is what happens when you disconnect it from like somebody's
individual actions. If you just If you try to say, "Oh, well,
you know what?
Technically, like yeah, Destiny doxes people and it's bad.
Right? But, you guys won't disavow your doxxers." It's like,
"No, I totally disavow anybody around me like doxxing
Obviously. Trying to compare Oh, dude, is anybody going to take
debates on this over the Nek Andro stuff? Cuz I didn't get a
stab at this, okay? I didn't get in that conversation and you
are just wrong if you're talking about what Nek Andros did is
doxxing. You are a loser. I'm sorry. You are wrong
So, if anybody wants to actually debate this, I'm perfectly happy
to have a discussion. Anybody on that side, you want to You want
to step in? You want to have this argument? Let's go. Cuz it's
going to turn out only one way. You are going to compare doxxing
people because you are having a manic crash or because you share
with all of your friends to a bunch of random women to trying
to assert ascertain whether or not one person is harassing a
victim of assault because it's the person because they're related
to the person who did this assault. Investigating that one question
with no malicious intent, no intent to harass is the same as
whatever Destiny's doing. That's what you're trying to collapse
and you will look psychotic trying to argue that.
Such such a disgusting disingenuous thing to do. You are all
hacks. You are all rats who are desperately trying to clog the
holes in your sinking ship because you know if you flee you anyway.
You would flee. Rats would normally flee the sinking ship but
they're trying to keep that ship afloat because they know they
can't succeed anywhere else that this is the only place that
their conduct will be accepted. So come on, argue it. Anybody
wants to argue it, okay? Any of the Necandro stuff? Holy By the
way, I don't know if Nick's Nick's arguing something about Chud.
I I don't know that stuff well enough to argue the Chud stuff
but anybody who's trying to like collapse the Necandro stuff
to oh that's just doxing, you. Oh, Stardust did a reply or something.
Give me a second. It talks about this. No no downplaying. I just
don't trust men like you who grandstand about this
It's not grandstanding.
It's literally
I think all men So actually when you pretend you're against that's
just fake virtue signaling. So I'm going to make it so it seems
like everybody actually.
How about you just say yeah, you're right. This is really bad
behavior and I'm going to say agree with you and just not try
to paint everybody's for no
I I don't know.
Before Pixie brought a lawsuit, wasn't your group making fun
of her for Sugar and Spice?
Oh, I see. There were people like no that's not Dicker's group.
There were people in spicy chat who were making fun of her and
that's like that is the kind of dark humor that happens. What's
up bro? How's it going?
What the [__] is with this like
cuz you can't prove that it's not normal, right? Cuz I don't
think there's like any sort of studies on if men share
right? Well, it's kind of like Well, I think when I think when
phones first came out, I think there was a pretty big culture
of people like sharing stuff like casually, probably not even
to group chats, more like pulling your phone out and like being
like oh look or something. I think that existed. I didn't hang
out with groups. I you know, I grew up late enough that I was
hanging out with like woke people in college and they thought
that was was just wrong.
Like I get Hanging out with wokies? Hell yeah, it's >> I
was I hung out with smart people and smart people tend to be
wokies. What can you do? That's epic. But I'm just saying >> Um
It's like yeah, people didn't want to do that around me. I think
Is my mic okay by the way? Do I sound fine? Yeah, it's fine.
Okay, okay. Uh Yeah, I don't It's just like cuz you can't disprove
that, right? It's literally just saying like
Cuz I was arguing with someone a while ago and that the argument
doesn't matter, but it's like I made like a common sense like
oh, it's just common sense. And he's like no, it's not like you
can't argue that. There's no you can't prove that. There's no
way to prove that. You have to actually use like something tangible
that you can point at or look at or touch or whatever. And it's
like yeah, why why even make the argument that it's normal to
do even if it's normal to do. Like if it was normal to do, would
this argument still work? Like oh, it's just normal to
Yes, it's about what the argument is in service of. Yes.
It's about >> work for any other immoral action ever. I
don't understand why she thinks it works here. And like I read
this and obviously I'm like I don't Yeah, if if someone I don't
think it's normal first off. Um I hope it's not normal. I don't
know if there's a way to prove if it's normal or not, but like
regardless
Like why even try to argue it? I don't I don't understand. It
only serves to like downplay what Destiny did. Um
And like her entire little speech is kind of serves to do that
as well cuz she's like I understand that Pixie's a victim and
all these other people are victims, but also Destiny's a victim.
And it's like
You've just like walked in on a guy a girl and then he kicked
the guy the in the balls.
And then you think to yourself oh, the the girl's obviously a
victim here, but isn't the guy also a victim in a way? It's like
well, come on. Like what the [__] are we doing? Like
sure, technically he's a victim, but it's like Like he he can't
you can't distract from him violating her consent 3 years ago
to his like you can't excuse that or explain it cuz he did that
before and totally disconnected from his consent being violated
and the all this being leaked years later, right? Like it's Disgusting
them together. I don't give a [__] if he's a victim.
It doesn't make any sense to talk about it in regards to Pixie.
He was not a victim when he did this to Pixie. He you can't farm
victim points and make it okay. It's totally insane to argue
this. Sorry, go ahead. I don't know, man. It it it feels
And I'm sure the crazy part is I'm sure DGG people feel the exact
same way, probably. But it just feels like insane cuz I think
to myself like
the obvious answer here
is like I don't care if people are fans of Destiny. I don't care
if people even watch Destiny, but it's like the weird dishonesty
about what he's done is just so bizarre and I don't understand
what it serves to do. It's particularly egregious and disgusting
from the people who said I can't be around this person or I'm
like distancing from this person because of what they did. And
now you come out and you're like, well, actually technically
like all men do this and also like didn't you guys make fun of
Pixie? Did she start this really distance? Cuz I tried to look
into that. I don't think she did. >> I think she retweeted
some Nick De Oreo. She got blocked for it. She was on team Nick
De Oreo, right? But now now these people see that like there's
a group who's calling them out on their and they're like, oh
my god, we got to close
Close ranks around the
I've got I have to watch her initial
I I think it's um I didn't I had I had a decent amount of respect
for Lonerbox. Not that I watch his content or anything, but I
thought he had strong
Um and I had like an amount of
respect for Hutch.
I kind of lost all that when he like cuz he he moral frogged,
I guess for lack of a better term, pretty hard when the Pixie
[__] initially happened, but he slowly like weaseled
his way back in. So after I saw that, I was kind of like, don't
know if I support this guy anymore. But,
I had like sir I had an amount of respect back then. >> He
was I think I think it's somewhat
but I think he's I can't I I've sort of understand his mentality.
Um yeah, I should try to fix that before it's too late.
Anyway, I don't think he like has gone back to Destiny or something.
I think the issue is a lot of his fans are >> think he's
gone back to Destiny. I think he's he's moving towards that though
or moving towards like a complacency. >> unfortunately
for him, he's like sort of his He had like a bad and people he
he is very upset or he is very annoyed at this concept. I think
he had his own fan base. He had a very like a substantial fan
base of his own that was growing and I think he pivoted at a
time based on evidence. I think he investigated himself down
this he like sort of started clubbing a little bit more with
Destiny and I think he got started having people in his audience
who were willing to link him stuff and I think he just happened
to get like very
Man, I think it's it's just kind of rough seeing how it over
time he gets like a little bit more like leaning
Israel and I think
there were people in his audience who sort of moved away with
that and then Oh, I >> up with like a lot of the overlap
the same audience overlapping
and then >> Sure. No, I I get what you're saying. I don't
think he's direct I don't think he's I I don't I don't think
it's going to literally be like
I like Destiny again. But, I do think it's going to be like a
you're basically just an orbiter again. And I think he's at that
stage where he's basically just an orbiter again without like
you know, outright saying I'm an orbiter or whatever. >> It's
the thing is that all these people need to realize is like that
community is just thoroughly poisoned. That community it is it
is like a cult it operates like a cult. You will never get you'll
never be allowed to be as cool as Destiny in any way. You will
never be able to grow past Destiny in any way so long as you're
like attached there and you have like a significant audience
overlap, it will always be in service of Destiny, okay? The The
thing I was trying to say though, basically, is it
it's very disappointing to see Lonerbox, Hutch, all of these
people run with the snark Discord narrative, because I want to
think that they're also with Lonerbox as well. He him kind of
like skitzing out at My Waifu like not even like making a video,
I think.
I don't know the specifics there fully, but it's like I I don't
Did she do anything other than just like disagree with the Israel
thing and then start making a video? And he like completely just
kind of like went a bit crazy over that, it feels. Well, I think
he had problems with My Waifu. Dude, I don't actually know
I don't know the full story. >> I feel like there's something
going on there that I can't see, cuz how obsessed he was
how obsessed he was with My Waifu and like angry at her makes
no sense to me. It actually like it even given like I I feel
like I've talked to a lot of different parties, and I feel like
everybody's told me what they think the facts are, and I'm sitting
here like Dude, there has to be something else.
There There's something else going on here. There's something
cuz to me I'm sitting here and this it doesn't make any sense.
Cuz he he he got like so angry about her.
Running with the whole snark in general though is just super
disappointing, because it it seems like
like it I don't know like it feels obvious to me, I should say.
I don't know if it's obvious to everyone, cuz obvious some
do not get the servers and are genuinely convinced that there
was like some evil doxing [__] happening there. But
it's like it feels like to me you should be able to come and
look at that and come away
understanding that it wasn't doxing and that these people weren't
like, you
doing crazy insane [__]
I I and to see these people like run with that,
it's like
like I don't It just feels so lowly of them, right?
Like why why run with that narrative? That's obviously coming
from DGG. That's obviously coming from Dan and Destiny. Did you
see that tweet that Spider made where he's like, "I'm not a DGGer."
and it's like you got the screenshots from
Dan censored the screenshots and sent them to you to post. What
the [__] are you talking about? >> Spider's
like 18. He's like fundamentally functionally
not because he's actually but because he's 18. Like he's just
I talked to him in the Discord before. I thought he was chill.
I thought he was like a cool guy but he's like totally [__]
[__] >> he's just like
it people that young you could just manipulate very easily.
And most people have like a constitution
like uh morality to them that prevent them from doing that.
certain other people don't.
All you need to know.
Okay? Yeah. Um
Destiny's Do you know what the manifesto is that Destiny's been
saying he's working on? Do you know what that is or what's going
to be in it? I mean I assume it's going to be how I mentally
everybody around him into
like leaving him or Lauren me and Lauren did or something like
this. I think that's the general narrative. Is it about you or
is it about like the
>> why he got sued. It's about
What is it about? It's about that. It's
the server of the Snark Left Discord. He's trying he has to prove
basically and why anybody gave him this opportunity to like take
so long to do this while totally looking the other way while
he was doxxing people is beyond me because it didn't just lead
to, you know, one person being harassed or one person having
their information leaked or like multiple failed doxx attempts
that leave them stressed all the time.
It is
it's it's lots of people, okay? Lots of people been harassed.
But nobody held him to the idea that he would prove that me or
Kweiman were involved in doxxing and he has not done that. He's
not even come close and nobody's tried to hold him to this. And
they're cowards for not doing it, right? But that is fundamentally
what he's leaning towards. He's trying to He's desperately trying
to prove that me or Kweiman were involved in some kind of doxxing
because he lost his mind. He is totally He has no self-control
and he started like going after people, trying to find their
information, calling for openly on his stream saying he would
dox them, right? And then he's publishing information about people.
So, when he when he puts all of this When he puts all of this
out, now he needs to prove that there was a reason he said that.
And so he's desperately trying to find something that connects
it because he really truly believed it and I believe he's slowly
starting to realize that that connection doesn't exist cuz it
couldn't exist cuz
something we actually stand on. Do you know what I mean? So,
he's like crash got more.
That's what I think the man of That's a big supposed to be a
big chunk of the manifesto is proving that. I think that's why
he's saying the Discord existed for 2 years even though that's
an obvious lie.
The most frustrating thing to me uh and I've said this on like
streams or whatever, it's just like the issue isn't even like
they don't actually have a moral issue here. They're not looking
at anything that's going on and saying, "I have an issue with
this." They're looking at it and they're pointing and they're
like, "Oh, look. These guys, they're actually just as bad as
us." They're So, they're not even like trying to deny doxxing.
They're not even trying to like say like, "No, we don't dox.
These guys dox. Like they're the ones that are doing, you know,
all this shit." They're not even doing that. It's just like,
"Oh, no, they're just hypocrites. We're We're bad people. We
do bad things, but they also do bad things." It's just like there's
no I don't know. That's just the most frustrating part. There's
just nothing for them to grab onto other than like
What you guys are just as bad. It's like
I don't know. Just [clears throat]
It's really
I'm glad Listen, I was never a big Destiny guy and I'm glad I
can say that, okay? I was never I listened to the JonTron debate
and I laughed and that's it, okay, dude?
It's um it's like this concerted effort to like Destiny is a
bad person. He's like a bad person or if you're not so erudite,
he's like flawed and he's like damaged.
Okay? But he's like a bad person. And so they need to make everybody
else who doesn't like him a bad person. That's like foundational.
That's how this group operates. They don't have anything they
stand for. They're just like everybody's as bad as Destiny deep
down inside. That's like broadly what they're trying to go for,
And that's just not true. That's why I'm This is another reason
you call me gay cuz I'm like we're better people. We're more
moral than these people. That's actually something I'm trying
to stand on is like you should actually try. I don't know if
I'm like a virtue ethicist, but I'm like on my way there or something.
>> It was just funny. It was just funny, >> It's
fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's but like I do think you should
broadly try to do like something good, especially if you're involved
in politics. Like could you imagine being involved in politics
and your only principle is do no harm?
Or sorry, not even do no harm, but mitigate harm. That's like
it.
You like anything you don't have anything else?
Yeah, they just want to make everybody look like total pieces
of like them.
Yeah, I think listen, I think it's fine
to you know, make mistakes and do you every now and again. But
like
I think the the the main thing for me is how you respond to that.
I don't think everybody's going to be perfect, right? Whether
it's you, whether it's Destiny, whether it's any of these people.
I think you're probably going to say or do
just respond to it
in a way that's like graceful, in a way that's not completely
uh or the best that you can. Just like try to try to be good.
You don't have to be good, but as long as you're like
Uh look like
Unironically, uh look at people like Pisco, right? It seems like
Pisco like has his goal in mind. He wants to, you know, do certain
things, and he's doing certain things, and none of those things
doxing or rolling around in like internet mud past like what
he does like I mean, okay, I say that he's you know, obviously
sperging out on Twitter with randoms using ChatGPT or whatever,
but you get what I mean. Like
None of what he wants to do online or like soy pill even, right?
Maybe it's not the best example, but he wants to do like political
advocacy.
None of what political advocacy entails
you know, roll around in the on Twitter
and and call them
So, yeah, I I that's that's the main thing. It's like you you
I don't even know if Destiny wants to do
at this point. When he's like doing manifestos on J stalking
queen men, it's like, come on. >> was just to onboard women
that he could to be honest with you.
I don't know if that's the sole reason. I think he cares about
it to an extent.
I like
he cares about it to an extent that it's something he could be
correct on.
I think Vaush soul read the guy that like Destiny's politics
are just about being like the correct person. Like it's not about
standing on any principle. It's just being most precisely correct
in any given instance. And so, but I think he does that so that
he be, you know, famous and and the debate bro guy. And then
that's like I think that sounds really stupid. He just wanted
women, man.
I I I really do. I don't want to get too gross or whatever, but
like I feel like you don't even need that to
I've gotten a lot while being like a complete and wrong in most
cases even. So. I think he also like he is he's good at it. Like
for for all Destiny's faults, I won't say that he like sucked
at it. He was like good at at farming these debates and winning
them or at least making it look like he won them,
That's it. You know what I mean? So, it was like his best tactic.
It was like the best tactic. He made a bunch of money doing it,
too.
>> Okay, sorry. I We got to open up the clip. Okay, hold
on. We got a quick Stardust clip here. What's this What's this
awesome Stardust clip? But, I I can't really comment on that.
I do know that um I mean I I feel like it's kind of hypocritical
to be um blaming him for being part of a forum, right? >> the
[__] up, you stupid [__] Really?
>> Oh, Jesus Christ.
What the [__]
Who is that? What did she do? I don't even know who that is.
>> blaming him for being part of a forum, >> the
[__] up, you stupid [__] Really? So,
Stardust, I guess, here is saying, "Even though Destiny was on
Kiwi Farms and posting in threads that had other people's doxes
in them, that's what it sounds like to me. I don't know if you
can blame him for that. Can you blame him for those doxes?"
And this was the line that every Destiny orbiter took when the
Keffals manifesto was coming out, right? This stupid
Okay, sorry. I don't have a I don't have a fantastic moral for
[__] so I don't really have anything to have finish
that with. Apparently, she's talking to Keffals right now. Blaming
him for being part of a threat that is engaged in so much harassment
that my mother's address was leaked and they went after my family.
How discourse brained are you that this is actually something
that you would say? Holy
Uh so, I'm not trying to get you mad or anything like that. >> Okay,
then actually be a person. Right. I I've expressed So, just like
a total psychopath, right? Like a total psychopath that has flipped
on this issue 180 perfectly in line with Destiny. As Destiny
has flipped with no principle whatsoever, Stardust has also >> So,
this is about Flamenco, not Destiny, by the way. Oh, it's about
Flamenco? Okay, either way. >> so remind of Flamenco got
on stream and threatened to send letters designed to his mom
because he thought he wasn't making enough money online or some
stupid [__] like that. So, that's the guy that started
us defending there, just to Just to be clear though, the the
principle still has flipped with Destiny as Destiny's flipped
on this. Well, I guess she might not have had it originally with
Destiny. Wait, was this before or after the manifesto? It's got
to be before, right? It's before the manifesto came out, but
this is the position they were all defending up to the manifesto.
Because Destiny had been posting in Kephal's Kiwi Farms thread
and she had been a I don't know whether Destiny posted in the
Kiwi Farms thread, but Destiny defended Flamenco as well. There's
a whole section on Flamenco in the manifesto.
I'll send you all the stuff now. >> One second, yeah, sure.
Sure.
Real quick. Okay.
I've not posted the thread link in my chat. I never made a post.
I've never made a post in that thread. Most of the information
Oh, he hasn't made a post in that thread. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Why did I think he did? Dude, he There's a post somewhere where
he's referencing that thread, is there not? I'm almost positive
I've seen a post where he's mentioning that thread.
on July 18th, she claimed that I posted in Kiwi Farms. >> wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. I'm almost positive in my in my mind I remember
a post that was made of him basically
like on Kiwi Farms, might be in his own thread, talking with
the Kephal's thread where he like asked something. I'm almost
positive that this exists. I think so. >> He asked He asked
something in his chat about the thread. He posted the thread
link in his chat. He just says he didn't do it multiple times.
He says he did once.
I don't post thread link in my chat multiple times, neither have
I ever encouraged my viewers to get involved. I'm pretty sure
he linked the thread once. He was linking like some image in
the thread or something. Yeah, yeah.
And she was mad because it included her dead name, not because
of a doxx
Yeah, yeah. So, I mean, you can argue that's you know revealing
dead names really new PII that's a the purpose of harassment.
So, this would be Play the clip. Play the clip. Play the clip.
You get out of my chat. Get out of my Get out of my Discord.
Get the [__] out of here, man. Did I get you mad
or anything like that? >> Okay, then actually be a person.
Right. I I've expressed to you that I don't approve of doxing
and I don't >> He's in your chat. Yes, he's in my chat.
>> you don't approve of him being in Kiwi >> He knows
that I don't approve of doxing, but So, but you're okay with
people who engage in that in your community because he's there
right now. I mean, I don't think people in my community engage
in that. Nobody in my community is doxing >> not part of
your community? Is he not in your chat just like you said? >> He's
a much bigger He has a much bigger community than Did she call
her At the end of this I don't remember or not. We had this platforming
discussion 5 minutes ago. We had the platforming discussion.
He's in your chat. You're not doing anything. You don't care.
This is just Unless Unless you have Unless you have screenshots
I'm willing to ban him if you have screenshots of him posting
doxx, but He didn't post doxx. He engaged in the thread. He engaged
in a group harassment campaign.
stupid that you can't see that this is the issue. The issue is
that he engaged in a group. So, again, just because people hate
on me, right? And that And I can say the same thing about when
people have been directed hate towards me, I just because they've
engaged in it doesn't mean they're also responsible for every
single thing that happens as a result of that hate.
He is He's part of the group that is responsible directly.
He directly encouraged it. I've seen this be said about me. I've
seen Cozy's stream where he uses memes that use content from
the thread. How is he not culpable here?
What kind of content does he use from the thread? Oh, shut the
[__] up. You want me to like pull up the Nazi site
and look over his memes? I mean, I I don't The reason why I'm
asking is because I don't know. I haven't paid >> You don't
know.
I came here to talk about you and me, not about him. This is
why I'm mad.
Because you have no morals. You have no principles. You're willing
to just stand by people who engage in group harassment a forum
that multiple trans people have killed themselves over. >> coordinated
group harassment of plenty of other people. >> Group harassment?
Group harassment? Do you have anyone who has to lock their door
at night because they're scared because they get like hate mail
directed to their house because they're associated with that?
I've said that
Yes, I would like to say is like hearing Destiny today is like
hearing Destiny today. Hearing Keffals rant like this. This is
literally what Destiny says.
This bit, dude. They're calling him like Keffals 2.0 like 3 months
in. >> But yeah, it's it's crazy that But it's crazy I've
not I've not gone back and actually watched this stuff since
all this has happened. Only in the last day or two have I actually
bothered to go back and look at any of this. I saw this clip
earlier and I was just like, "No, I cannot believe this nasty
I truly cannot."
Can't? I mean, let's be honest. Well, it's like it this is like
literally >> case, right? No, but this is like next level
man. Like she this is like one of
defining moments online to be honest is getting called a by Keffals
because she was, you know, uh making a totally valid argument
about KF and responsibility.
I I understand um
that she's arguing like you should ban Flamenco cuz he's engaging
in the threat. Uh was there like an explicit
defense of his threats like with the letters to Xander Hall?
>> No, I'm not I'm not saying that No, no, no, no. I'm
I'm not saying they defended that action. I'm saying >> No, no,
no. I'm not I'm not Yeah, I'm just wondering if there was that,
but if there's not, then sure. I'm not No, he's I'm saying that
their standard now makes no sense because it it just it literally
just Imagine just let's transplant some variables here, okay?
Uh let's let's replace Flamenco with Nakandros, okay? Nakandros
has sent letters to Knox's mom, okay? Or he he was joking about
sending letters to Knox's mom threatening to whatever.
then uh uh this exact same thing happens. What would Stardust's
perspective be on that now? Obviously, it would be, "This This
guy's insane. He's part of a harassment brigade. He's trying
to
That's what That's what her perspective would be now. And she
says the same Literally in that tweet, she's saying to
"Aren't you part of the group that harasses man like the the
this totally contradicts that." Dude, was Dickers even like a
thing? Did he have an account made with that name? Like did he
literally he's getting blamed for something that he was not around
for, >> Wasn't even around for, yep. By the way, I've made
it clear Ethan Klein, when you're when CPS was called, I was
defending you, okay? I was like I was literally like, "Oh dude,
what are you supposed to do? CPS is really bad."
Dude, she's such a self-victimizing loser. It's so gross. Uh
give me a second. Who are the quickest people to demean women
in this broader community for their sex activity or non-activity,
use their bodies to demean women for uh whether they've had children
or not? Ooh. I I'd like Could these people just name names to
make it less confusing?
Like just name the names. >> avoid that broadly. I have
to really, really, really, really hate them. Because generally
I find it quite uncouth. And I found this all out to laugh or
used to. I got I feel like that's like the red pill people do.
Like, "Oh, your womb's drying up. You even have kids, bitch."
Like I don't think I've ever heard anybody in this space say
that. I'm pretty sure I've never done that. If someone's talking
like like calling other people like losers and they're like,
you know,
35, no family, like I'll point that out. But I do that for men,
too. It's not about women, right? It's like Oh. Yeah, yeah, there's
like plenty of situations where I'll make a comment like that,
but broadly I don't think I demean women for their sex activity
or non-activity, use their bodies to demean women for whether
they've had children. I don't think I broadly do that. Oh.
Use their bodies. I don't know what that even means. Yeah, no
idea. Like talk their their body?
Cuz maybe I've done that. >> I mean oh, like baby stream?
No. Well, yeah, I don't I don't know what she means. If she means
like
Yeah, I know. I Use their bodies against them or something? Like
she gets called fat all the time, you call her hog dirt? Like
that, maybe? Oh, oh, wait. So okay, so you literally you call
cool people fat because when you do it to women, you're massaging
your ego. Okay, that's what it is. >> I guess. I don't
know. You're all the same in my book until proven otherwise.
Prove the negative, guys. Prove you've never shared with any
woman online.
Dude. Okay.
Okay. You all made fun of and demeaned women multiple women and
leaked images and shared them further. You're disgusting. No.
No. >> Nope. No. No. Nope. >> No. Explicitly opposite,
actually.
Dude, I yeah, it's These people It's so
And you were you were saying this to Stale last night and I noticed
the same thing that like
for somebody like Stale or somebody like Erodite or somebody
like Stardust, literally they would rather like they would rather
be friends and close to a two goes like, "You're really smart."
Then have somebody come along and go, "You're making the dumbest
argument ever." And they're like a good person otherwise. Like
if you're rude to them, that is the highest crime. That is the
highest sin in their opinion.
It's bizarre, right? It's a bizarre I don't I don't get it. Like
I would much rather have a friend who like is able to be a good
person and >> to even respect someone if they can't be
rude to me, frankly.
That's That's
I just I don't Yeah, I don't get it. But Oh, hold on. Who leaked
the nude? And respond. And did Matt just continue associating
with said individual? Uh not spread choice of not spread it further.
It wasn't spread further. It was not spread further. I have a
quick question for you, man.
>> Um Have you or have you not done uh Stardust hog rider
memes?
Yeah. Don't you think that's like unfair to do like a for a like
a young woman as herself? You don't think Don't you think that's
demeaning? I don't think it's misogynistic to call women fat.
In fact, if you call women fat too. I think she's uh average
weight,
Thank you, Kenny. Um Did you see her in the That That is what
a Jamaican would say, Kenny. That is what a Jamaican would say.
Okay.
>> Back to the islands, Kenny. Back to the islands. Actually
islands. Six months on the islands for you, Kenny. >> Well,
well, well, okay for me. Okay. Okay for me. You want to go there?
You want to go there? Have a track record of abusing Indians,
okay? Yeah, but she should be defending me. She should be on
my team.
Okay, buddy. Okay, we I've not done the rest of these Decker
sweets. She should be posting Queman is lying. Queman is lying.
That's what she should be saying on Stardust Twitter right now.
But no. All right, I need to read these Decker sweets. Okay,
we need to go through these. It's not something you should do
to a friend. You say he would admit he did You say he would admit
he did wrong. He has argued he had implied consent. He's argued
explicitly the opposite, you stupid [__] I'd love
to probe the this distrust of men, but I Sorry, I'm not exactly
the misogyny stuff. I'd love to have I'd love to probe this distrust
of men, but I I have more faith in Beckett's sense of shame
than to imagine he willingly showed your nasty to anyone.
What the [__] [laughter] That's a That is a That
is a Ethan Ralph quote used with poetic license. This is an He's
just Okay, buddy. He's She's allowed that comment with like relatively
little concern before, so he's just reusing it,
Yeah, why are there no quotation marks? Typical deflection plus
ad hominem. You've proven my point. No answers to my questions.
Just You're ad hominem-ing me. You shouldn't have an ad hominem.
You're ad hominem-ing me.
>> I counter base, actually. Uh what?
I mean, the answer to the questions is quite literally just I
wasn't a part of that group. I literally wasn't around for that.
I've no idea what Blitz is talking about right now. Why is he
losing all of the drama? I'm sure he just wasn't around for it.
He just not You know, he wasn't in the community, Yeah. Yeah.
Okay, I'll put your nasty to one side for now. On the topic of
my crowd spicy chat, can you tell me what has changed in your
positions now versus during the Kephals versus Destiny drama?
I can't listen to this right now. I'm in bed and I don't want
to wake someone, but I also don't
Don't know what that is. Too poor for AirPods. Too poor for AirPods.
Get a job. Get a job.
Literally nobody cares. That's gross. >> That's gross.
Shut up. I didn't want to know that. Just say I'm not Just don't
respond, actually. Just respond tomorrow. >> You guys are
disgusting.
Also, I'm sorry this is like code, but you can actually totally
listen to things on your phone without waking someone next to
you.
Yeah, you could. Again, listen to this right now, I'm in bed.
I don't want to wake someone, but I also don't really care to
engage with you beyond this point. You've avoided all my questions,
so I'm going to disregard yours. Can you give me a single point
I didn't engage with?
Actually, go on bed, man. Go on the bed.
Did anybody who pulls all like I actually have is uh
I hate it. Dude, the picture that Destiny posted earlier today
to J Stalk. It's like, "Sorry, I couldn't reply. I was I I just
got out of the shower." >> sex. I'm I'm busy having sex.
I'm busy having sex. Yeah.
I Honestly, like the picture that Destiny posted earlier today
to J Stalk, it's like gross, but how do you not know how everyone
else is going to Like you just made Hassan's week by posting
that. And you can't even identify that. It's so sad. It's actually
like low-key It's like you need It's time Put down the phone
20 minutes.
Consider what your next response is. You know? Yeah. It's wild,
man. Oh, it is but it is like Dude, I swear to God there was
a DGG thread that went up where they're all like, "OH MY GOD,
MY MY GOAT HAS Oh my god, he like he has Oh, he's so awesome."
All of them All of them. Hundreds of people are like >> I
I wish I could do that. Dude, it's so depress- It's so
It's just black-pilling, man. It's gross. Yeah. It's pretty nasty.
You guys were a part of that, remember? We didn't pull that one
really, actually. And uh Actually, don't I actually play video
games and make YouTube videos? I actually have two kids already.
>> And you're a dancer. Professional. Yeah. Well, well,
I think we're done with Uh finish finish Wait, finish this clip.
Finish this clip. I came here to talk about you and me, not about
him. This is why I'm mad. >> J Stalk, try. Because you
have no morals. You have no principles. You're willing to just
stand by people who engage in group harassment on a forum that
multiple trans people have called themselves over. You coordinated
group harassment of plenty of other people. Group harassment?
Yes, you have. Do you have anyone who has to [__]
lock their door at night because they're scared because they
get [__] like hate mail directed to their house because
they're associated with you? I've said that that's not right.
But but two but two wrongs don't two wrongs don't make a right.
in your community who you interact with, who you call friends
because you're a [__] snake. >> But I need
I need screenshots of him actually posting docs. >> I'll
get all of those He didn't post the [__] docs. He
engaged in group
She is Yikers. >> It's gold. It's gold. It's gold.
It's platinum. It's a platinum clip. Really blame him for that?
Can you really blame him that you have to lock your doors at
night? Is that really his fault? Just cuz he was like kind of
around these people a little bit? Come on. He encouraged if he
encouraged other people by engaging in group Do you know what
group harassment is? You have more than two brain cells? Jesus,
Stardust. >> I know I understand what group harassment
is. I've had people on Cozy direct their entire followings to
come hate raid me. So I understand what that is. But I I still
need to see like like more than somebody just participating in
being, you know, harassed or something, right? thread in the
same thread on a site I think she calls her What was that you
said? What was that What did she say there? Are you How is She
has to say more than just being antagonistic towards somebody.
Wow. Oh, interesting.
[__] brain cells? Jesus, Stardust. >> I understand
what group harassment is. I've had people on Cozy direct their
entire followings to come hate raid me. So I understand what
that is. But I I still need to see like like more than somebody
just participating in being, you know, harassed or something,
right?
More than just, you know, people being when you're going through
it. You know?
You know, it turns out And you might be
And, you know, the whole world might be against you right now,
but, you know, just because some people piling on the forum that
you that doesn't mean that everyone there is guilty, you know?
Just because just because there's some like guy who threatens
to send letters to people's homes and he's piling on to you in
a forum that's like doxing the [__] out of you. It
doesn't mean you get to blame him for it, you know? He's actually
an okay guy.
I wish everybody had their opinions back here, you know? Yeah,
I actually I actually quite like the half of his manifesto. I
think you know that was actually quite quite a good a good moment
in Destiny's career to be honest. Um so I so I do wish you know
this was still maintained.
Like I don't I don't even think it's necessarily true that they
share no blame. It's just that they don't share the blame, right?
Like people want to attach it as if they were doing the Dude,
maybe maybe you know, you want to distance or not be You know
what I mean? Like at least at least give like you know, some
tepid pushback or something. But it's just
I don't know. It's
It's obvious that you can't just blame them for everything.
It seems obvious to me.
Seems like it's also obvious that everybody's only flipped on
this now because Destiny's flipped on this. Actually, it's it's
the one bad apple argument, okay? One bad apple spoils the
Yeah, I saw I heard that like crying about me uh she's like it's
so weird that he cozied up with Beckett. It's so it's so weird
he goes on about it. The Dutch yourself scared so I mean I'm
sorry. Shouldn't she be I think that's kind of weird. No offense
to Beckett, but shouldn't she be angry at Beckett? Isn't that
Beckett's trail? Like I'm sorry. >> I I cozied up to make
How can I just I was on streams saying I'm going to make Beckett
my best friend. I'm going to make Beckett my best friend. I was
saying this it was a joke about the fact that obviously I hate
Star Dust and she hates me and nothing would piss her off more
if I was like tied with Beckett. I was joking about that. I think
Beckett whether it was to be or not. >> That's like your
your short beta otaku story, okay? I'm going to I'm going to
go find this person. I'm going to be best friends with them as
like a form of revenge. Wouldn't it be really funny if I'm friends
with the future >> I'm friends with the boyfriend of this
guy I really
It would. That would be funny. Is that
It is funny. Yeah, it is funny. It's not I'm not talking about
the truth claims, yeah. I'm I'm about like you as a human, you
know? Methodological as a human
All right, what's what's wrong with that, Kenny? What's wrong
with that?
I just don't like making women feel unsafe and you were really
an unsafe individual and you're like creeping into her life,
you know, like stalkerish. Like you're like, "Oh, I can't speak
to her directly, so I'm going to go through the boyfriend." So,
I know, that's how I see it. I'm like a proud duster.
Proud duster? Proud duster.
Look at it like this. I'm just done talking about everything
until the case is over. So, there's always a reason to do it.
Either bad faith actors in the stalker community will try to
weaponize everything or trying to virtue signal like Willy Mac
Ethan will try to demonstrate their virtue to people.
I think this is um during when he had his fight with Ethan Klein
must have been, right? Yeah.
Dude, it's like he's talking to toddlers. He has to explain
One full year ago. Fast forward to today and this guy's like,
the biggest evils in politics are Trump, MAGA, and then Jace
Dock."
What are you talking about, man? Like
how do you not see this is just like the most mentally individual?
You know what I'm saying? But this guy will never respond to
anything any of his critics say with little any substance whatsoever.
Just like Trump, MAGA, Jace Dock, and all of the other weirdos
that have infected our politics now. The only Why? What? >> Jace
Dock has infected politics, right?
>> and talk about this to some DNC stuff or something,
bro. I don't know. Think you sound really smart.
Dude, him and Chad Logic have Him and Chad Logic with the started
set of DMs,
What I wouldn't do to bird this bird bird man.
What her account is snarking is legal. But and it's hard to explain.
I know people who watch this show understand
the [__] that we've been dealing with since all this
stuff.
But it's hard to understand like
this is a group of 50 people that have spent all day and night
24 hours a day unemployed
dedicated to ruining mine and many other people you know the
people's lives.
But this is like a specifically like yeah the clients. But the
logs drop and it's like 90% [__] fire bot [__]
He is going to try to find trans fire bot and figure out what
happened. How did this start? How did all of this start? How
did it begin?
What's going on here?